[Music]
hello I'm Ben Wattenberg Russia is in
turmoil war in Chechnya a stagnant
economy a faltering democracy but does
trouble for Russia mean trouble for
America helping us to answer that
question
our Leon Aaron resident scholar at the
American Enterprise Institute and author
of a forthcoming biography of Boris
Yeltsin Peter Rodman former national
security aide under presidents Reagan
and Bush and the author of a book about
the Cold War more precious than peace he
is currently at the Nixon Center for
peace and freedom
Peter Rutland a professor of government
at Wesleyan University and author of the
politics of economic stagnation in the
Soviet Union and Paula de Brienne ski
former director of European and Soviet
affairs for the National Security
Council under President Reagan and now
an adjunct fellow at the Hudson
Institute the topic before this house is
Russia a threat again this week on
think-tank
[Music]
for 40 years from an American
perspective the Soviet Union was the
most important foreign country then the
Soviet Union split apart the years
following the collapse of communism have
not been easy for Russia and the Berlin
Wall came down people on both sides of
the former Iron Curtain rejoiced
but today's mood is much more sober
Russia's gross domestic product has been
shrinking by 19% in 1992 and by 12% in
1993 inflation currently runs at 18% per
month and crime is increasing the
so-called Russian mafia controls an
estimated 40 percent of all transactions
and goods and services last December
Russian troops invaded the breakaway
Republic of Chechnya bombing its capital
of Grozny to rubble the death toll has
reached a reported 24,000 civilians
former republics like Ukraine and
Kazakhstan fear that Moscow might turn
expansionist and try to rebuild the
Soviet empire through coercion or even
outright invasion it is said that
president Boris Yeltsin once called the
George Washington of Russian democracy
is now overwhelmed by the job and
suffers from ill health perhaps
alcoholism many Russian Democrats like
former prime minister Jager guide are
have turned against Yeltsin hardline
nationalist parties are believed to be
rising in popularity and influence and
while Soviet Communism has been
relegated to the dustbin of history
Russia still has thousands of nuclear
weapons capable of hitting Western
Europe and the United States it used to
be a gentleman and lady that the views
on the Soviet Union were divided into
hawks and doves and now it seems to be
that they are divided between optimists
and pessimists and I just wonder it's
just to sort of establish where you all
are maybe we'll just go quickly around
the horn here starting with Leon Aaron
if you could just try to tell me where
you I think
I'm a very cautious optimist I think
it's it's a very cold spring we just had
a big chill with Chechnya and perhaps
Frost but it's still a sowing season
okay Peter Rutland
I'm also an optimist in the long term
although I wouldn't underestimate the
problems in the short term and in terms
of a threat Russia may be a threat to
its own people more than two people
beyond its own borders Paulette Aubrey
Husky in the short term I'm a pessimist
specifically because of the events in
Chechnya the fact that Moscow has waged
such barbaric actions and dealing with
the circumstances do not bode well for
the future lawlessness corruption is
still prevalent the legacy of communism
still has not been broken in the long
term maybe a cautious optimist in the
short term a pessimist
Peter Rodney I'm a pessimist Russia
Russia has always been a problem I mean
that's the history of Europe tell
teachers that Russia has always been a
big clumsy difficult powerful factor and
I think we're we're seeing that again I
wouldn't call Russia a threat I think
it's going to be a major problem I see
some disturbing trends in its foreign
policy and I think we need to be more
realistic about it than we have been
what why do people say and it is said
that Russia has always been a problem I
mean is there is that their geography is
that their psychology is it their
history I mean Leon you you grew up in
Russia yes well it certainly was a
problem for me as I was growing but well
I think it's there a number of things
been it's it's a positioning sort of
between Europe and Asia it's the
tradition of authoritarianism it's sort
of inability to decide whether they
belong to Europe with enlightenment and
free enterprise and democracy whether
they belong to Asia and it's also
perennial almost perennial insecurity
which largely was brought upon by its
own expansion that led a Russia to this
paradoxical situation that the more
expanded the more insecure it became I'm
not sure we should say it's a problem
I'm not sure any country can be
described as a
problem sure Russia has had a difficult
history but at various points in history
it's it's it's polled to Europe's bacon
out of the fire it's it's it saved
Europe from a sundry sundry dictators
from Napoleon to Hitler and sorry it's a
cycle of successes and defeats in Russia
right now is the the depths of a trough
but it will come back and I don't think
we should say that it's a demonic
country that they're doing I'm back as a
democracy well I think one of the
greatest concerns today especially is is
the fact that democracy has not taken
hold in the sense of the term in Russia
and especially that those countries in
Central and Eastern Europe are very
concerned about Russia's intentions
they're unclear take Ukraine for example
Ukraine is very concerned about the
events in Chechnya especially because
Russia has not really in all tents and
purposes fully acknowledged the
sovereignty and the existence of Ukraine
so the dust has not settled and in that
sense it does propose a problem
not only for us but for the for the
Europeans but Paul are you saying Russia
isn't a democracy but five years ago
would you have expected Russia to be
this democratic no I think that it has
made certain strides that is true but
still it is not a democracy in the
truest sense of the term clearly the
actions undertaken by Moscow in dealing
with the situation in Chechnya defy any
semblance of democratic peaceful act
peaceful actions with one exception Paul
it seems to me that indeed Chechnya was
a test for Russian democracy the
executive failed completely failed it
executive failed however there's one
silver lining the United States right I
don't want to sound as if I'm pro the
Russian government but the United States
was a democracy when we engaged in a
civil war dealing sort of with a quotes
breakaway republic I mean it's not in
just on its surface and outrageous but
no no I don't think so and and you know
that the the Kitchener regime itself the
diaphragm was far from democratic and
blameless for all of this but it failed
in its brutality it failed in its
ineptness its failed in the amount of
casualties that inflicted more
importantly I think its failed in the
way that that war was presented to the
people and the
executive work with the Parliament that
Peter ruckman the question you asked
with why is why is Russia a problem and
I think Leon described the historical
reasons very well but I would emphasize
one factor which is its power it is a
huge concentration of power in the
middle of the Eurasian landmass and it
is all it has always been a problem for
it's for anybody who had the misfortune
to live in its immediate neighborhood
and as Leon said it's been clumsy has
never been quite sure where it fit into
the sort of international system and I
think there's a relation of earning well
exactly like Germany and it's not an
accident of the history of the last the
century has been your Germany and Russia
either competing or taking turns
disrupting the peace and we may you know
I worry that we may be heading in no
right right now the balance of power in
Europe is benign but I think a lot of
that is because the United States is
sitting there as the stabilizer I mean
it's my policy concern for us which is
how do we you know stabilize the
situation make sure that it doesn't
become a big big a threat before it's
not a threat it's a problem why didn't
the Tocqueville when he came here I
guess in the 1830 say that the two great
nations of the future were gonna be the
United States and Russia what did what
did he sense there was a physical
physical power that was dormant and that
was inevitable if you were writing about
the world today say for the next hundred
years would you say those are the two
big powers still no it's it's more there
are more other players
Germany Japan China China and China
absolutely so it's a you know it's been
evolving into a bit more multipolar
system but they're still I mean Russia
is big and particularly because it's in
turmoil and it is scary to anybody who
lives in its immediate neighborhood
well just continuing with that with that
theme it seems to me that when I talked
about the silver lining this Chechnya
affair one thing that it did show is
that the Russian society is no longer
synonymous with the Kremlin that the
people did not buy the party line and
most importantly the media were
completely free to report something that
in its explicitness in candor I would
say was probably unequaled by
any country at war except for that of
the United States during Vietnam and
what the coverage that you saw on
national television during the Chechen
war utterly belied the notion that this
is an authoritarian regime in that
particular regard that it could crack
down in the media whenever it wanted so
it seems to me that while the executive
I repeat failed miserably in this war we
no longer could equate the Kremlin with
Russia something that is utterly new and
in my view quite quite optimistic Leon I
would agree with your point absolutely
that is the silver lining my reason
before for mentioning why I don't see
Russia at this time being a democracy in
the fullest sense of the term is is
because yes there have been free and
fair elections yes as you mentioned the
silver lining an important factor in the
crisis in dealing with Chechnya has been
the fact that there haven't been these
constraints on media that there has been
a vibrant media and in fact public
opinion has gone very much against the
actions of Moscow however there still is
not an independent functioning judiciary
there is no rule of law which is a
bedrock of any society that has not
taken hold and secondly although I think
the population has certainly become more
engaged in democratic ideas and values
the understanding in the grasp of it and
its translation into concrete action it
still needs to evolve what used to be
done what about the the commercial realm
we said in the setup piece that 40% of
the Soviet economy is run by the Mafia
but but that mafia or earlier the the
black market I mean that can be viewed
as sort of a rudimentary stage of real
capitalism you let all the illegal
enterprises flourish and then you you
regulate them I mean is that is that
plausible and the thing with it from the
rubber barons in American history to the
current situation in China we can see
that this sort of informal economy to
use a more polite terms and mafias the
to shade shade into one another the
informal economy is rife in every
economy in the world and in some
economies it's it's more prevalent than
others in some economies its legislators
that are getting shot down on the
streets we did have our robber baron
period well it also had a selling
protection
in the united states well but that's
that's a low collaboration we also we
had also had a legal system in a
political system and and as our society
evolved the legal system was able to
dominate these most for the most part
these these criminal elements russia
doesn't have a legal system or an
established political I mean everything
is in turmoil at the same time and
there's no guarantee it's going to
evolve smoothly into a nice bourgeois
you know writing society it has a
president Leon you are writing a
biography about mister Yeltsin and I
guess the the popular question is is he
a Democrat or a drunk and I want to both
or but it could be both it's a history
is replete with the Democrats dabbled
into all kinds of divergence where do
you come out well general view well I
think I think Yeltsin is is a man who is
generally in favor of democratic
development but who himself obviously
does not have the experience being the
party boss all his life that have the
experience or very much understanding of
the free market or democracy and I think
he was an ideal person for the
barricades but he must have been a great
temptation during Chechnya for such a
man to close down the press and yet he
did that's precisely and not only that
but then his in his address to the
nation he reaffirmed that with all his
problems that he has with the media he
still will not allow any sort of
crackdown in the media so I think
Yeltsin unfortunate like Gorbachev is a
man whose hour has passed I mean he won
the revolution there's no there's no
doubt about that but Russia now moved
beyond the barricades and in this space
between the revolution and democracy
Yeltsin is lost he he could not find his
proper niche and I think part of it part
of the reason he decided on this utterly
disasters both politically moral in the
lateral action in Chechnya is because he
was searching for a mission he was
searching for a way to establish himself
the question I would like to come back
to is whether Yeltsin if he leaves the
scene can be replaced is he actually
pivotal to the way that the political
elite works in Russia
that's the thing that worries me that
there may not be a clear transition to
another if if we go to chaos and anarchy
in Russia it's just cause for America to
worry I mean is that is this a huge
concern to us with the nukes rattling
around and well you put your finger on
it the nukes are the the main concern
and yeah well there were 20,000 I think
before then their arms control arms
reduction agreements that are bringing
it down under 10,000 more warheads
warheads and that process is going on
and we have a stake in it now so far the
Russians have had very good command and
control over their nuclear weapons but
the continuing deterioration of their
political authority you know could
change that I mean I think if Russia is
weak it obviously addresses the concern
I raised at the beginning that it's less
of a threat to its neighbors on the
other hand there's the the nuclear or
Anarchy which is enormously dangerous
and secondly I think there's an
Aristotelian cycle I don't think a great
power endlessly tolerates humiliation I
think there will be a return to some
central authority I mean you know a
strongman I think you will have I think
anarchy will inevitably be inevitably
produced some kind of authoritarian
regime so we'll be back maybe where we
started
capito when you say we could we might go
back to where we started well you're not
going to go back to the Soviet Union oh
I think in terms of its we're talking
about its internal evolution and the you
know with it we have the hopes for
democracy and I think if democracy turns
into anarchy it usually ends up in some
authority then goes retrograde we are
not as bad off as we were during the
Cold War well I have the whole I think
there's a big there's a big difference
between Russian foreign policy and
Soviet foreign policy I think is the big
improvement I mean Russia is a state I
think it's it has a sense of its
national interest or its groping for a
sense of its natural national interest
it doesn't have this Leninist
ideological thrust to disrupt the
Western position all around the world so
even I will worry about it I can see a
big difference Peter wouldn't you agree
though that although you said that
Russian foreign policy is not synonymous
with Soviet foreign policy that
nevertheless one of the problems are one
of the challenges with which we face
is that Russia as interests are not or
have not been in common with ours when
you look at the situation of Bosnia look
at the situation in the Middle East of
late as well as in Europe the handling
of NATO our interests or our directions
have been rather done the middle selling
nuclear reactors and submarines to Iran
which I think actually bothers me more
than Chechnya does because this impinges
directly on an area of vital interest to
us and this is one of the excuse me I
say this is one of the I think the
greatest challenges that we face that's
separate from what is evolving on the
domestic scene that internationally
instead of our interests be being more
parallel that they have become divergent
and there's a polarization well I think
I think Paul and Peter put put their
fingers on that I think there are
several aspects of Russian new Russian
foreign policy that need to be taken
into consideration I think to me the
Russian foreign policy globally not
talking about the backyard that's a
separate issue globally you sort of like
the goals France that is you lose in
substance what you try to acquire in
rhetoric and you try to show at least on
the rhetorical symbolic level that
you're not in US pocket for example for
example Bosnia is one example Iran is
another example debate is is still
pretty much within the Cold War scheme
of things where security is the dominant
factor in foreign policy I would suggest
that economics is much more important in
the present world the economic terms
there are lots of mutual interests
between the west and Russia and the
things about selling nuclear reactors to
Iran is purely economic if the Russians
don't sell them in five years time the
French or the Germans will be said more
point of view with the security because
of the Middle East and and but from the
Robinson it's economics right that's
what that made let me ask but how is the
Clinton administration doing if they
handle this situation well I don't think
that they have handled it forcefully and
directly in first of all on the issue of
Chechnya the comparison
this is similar to America's Civil War I
don't think was an appropriate parallel
secondly the Clinton administration make
that yes the initial statement was that
well this is an eternal matter and we
should wipe her hands of it
I don't think it can be viewed as an
internal matter it has ramifications for
Russia's development it has
ramifications for us from a security
standpoint and it certainly has
ramifications for a for Eastern Europe
secondly and very significantly I think
that the administration has put too many
eggs in yeltsin's basket and also has
placed too much of an emphasis on a
Russia oriented policy I think I think
Paul is right in the sense that it
should not be a Russia only but I think
we will all agree it should be Russia
first and the reason for that is not an
especial predilection for Russia but the
fact that if Russia goes down so will
other countries and you have those
nuclear weapons right around it nobody
if I may just jump in on that I don't
think I would say it should be Russia
first because psychologically I think
that sends a very wrong signal secondly
many of these countries just as much as
they are dependent upon the fate of
Russia I think if you do not have
democracy in Ukraine I think that is
very much intertwined with the future of
Russia if Ukraine does not succeed you
come out on how Clinton is done the
Clinton administration well I don't
think there's been an effective policy
either Russia first or Ukraine first
policy I think there's been just a
stasis in policy which in in the long
run will probably what policy stasis
there's been no real movement forward in
American policy and in the long run this
is probably a good thing because if
America had adopted a determined policy
earlier on it would probably be in the
wrong policy so better to just be an
observer on these process you know
Rodman you've generally been a critic of
the Clinton phone yeah I have been on
and on this one in particular I see it
in geopolitical terms I think Russia you
you need to hedge against a possible
reemergence of Russia and yet I see
which means that your if your first line
of defense is Russian democracy your
second line of defense is the
independence and security of all the new
states that have emerged from the
wreckage of the Soviet empire and that
so I think we have a
political stake in Ukraine and the
eastern you're in protecting the Eastern
Europeans and that's why I think the
Russia the the the disproportionate
foreign assistance that has gone to
Russia is a geopolitical mistake me we
have a stake in the independence of all
the others just in order to stabilize
the present situation and as a hedge
against the possible you know as I said
the emergence of Russia as a problem we
are running out of time let me just ask
you one personal question is five years
ago ten years ago the people who dealt
with the Cold War and the Soviet Union
were sort of at the top of the food
chain in Washington might you know that
was what was really important now the
Cold War is over do you find any
difference I mean the people not
returning phone calls I you no longer
invited to as many parties what foreign
policy as the whole is less important
and I worry about an isolationist mood
in the country because I think if the
United States would removes its
stabilizing role or its stabilizing
policy in the world and I think all
these problems would end up bigger than
they otherwise could be well then get
Henry Kissinger said famously that that
powers the ultimate attraction right the
ultimate aphrodisiac right exactly
no if I know but but I think I think
Peters right though
you know while the policy foreign policy
in general is changed
clearly I find that in retrospect that
that fear is also an ultimate attraction
and there's no doubt that the attention
that's given to Russia and to those who
are dealing with Russia is is not what
it used to be and but you're still
inviting us so well must be well but we
do more shows about welfare and
affirmative action in crime that we
probably would have done had this
program started five years ago or ten
years absolutely all right let me just
as a closing exercise here again we have
to do it sort of briefly picture of the
year 2002 which is when the buy of seven
years now when the budget is supposed to
be balanced here what will the Soviet
Union look like Russia right I'm sorry
well Russia look like I think it will
still be a country struggling
economically and politically but less of
a threat to its neighbors than at any
time in its fourth 100 year history I
think Russia will be seen as a major
economic partner it already supplies 50
percent of West Germany's gas needs it's
running a trade surplus we should stop
thinking of it as just having 20,000
nuclear weapons but start thinking of it
as a major trading partner I think that
authoritarianism will reign in Russia in
terms of the leadership I think there
will still be strong and vibrant
dissident groups trying to change that
but unfortunately politically I see
authoritarianism is raining well if
Russia gets back on its feet
economically by then I think it'll be
more of a problem than it is otherwise
meaning that it would be a great it'll
be stronger I think we'll have a bigger
problem in foreign policy you managed to
come out pessimist yeah either way all
right thank you
Leon Aron Peter Rodman Peter Rutland and
Paul dobri on ski and thank you we enjoy
hearing from our viewers very much
please send your questions and comments
to New River media one one-five-zero
17th Street Northwest Washington DC 2 0
0 3 6 or we can be reached by email at
think TV at aol.com for think-tank I'm
Ben wattenberg
[Music]
this has been a production of BJ W
incorporated in association with New
River media which are solely responsible
for its content